hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from round seven of this
year's Tata steel Masters Edition it is
Arjun Eric AC versus another of the
clash of the new younger generation of
uh Super Players uh both of them already
rated over 2700 and both of them having
a great tournament so far Arjun uh for
the first six games he drew all six
against very strong opposition uh and
the mother back of course if you've been
following what's been happening in the
Chess World he has defeated Magnus
Carlsen uh with the black beasts in
round five and then proceeded to get a
draw against pregnant and in game six
and now uh this is the game that we are
covering so let's dive straight into it
and see uh what this game is all about
so Arjun opens with Ponte E4 we have
Pawn to E5 Knight to F3 and now Knight
to F6 Abdul satro goes for the uh Petra
of Defense with Ponte D4 and Knight
captures on e4 so accepting the the pawn
to White Stein attack and now usually
you see Bishop to D3 here but here we
have D captures on E5 which is uh very
rare especially uh at top level chess uh
we have Pawn to D5 and now Knight beat
the D2 We have Knight captures on D2
Bishop captures on D2 and now Bishop to
E7 with Bishop to D3 and now Pawn to C5
grabbing some Central squares here we
have C3 and now Knight to C6 we have
castles in Bishop to G4 so just
continuing development by both sides uh
this has all been played before and not
just played this has been played in a
candidates Tournament game in 2018 in
Berlin uh but we're gonna get to that
Rook D1 and here uh the game that we
discussed is Alexander grishu versus
Fabiano Corona and uh caruana uh won
that game very nicely uh in that game uh
Queen to D7 was played and also there
are some like five or six games in the
database where Queen to D7 was played
but here we have Castles by another Beck
and it is now as of move 10 that we have
a completely new game so he finds sort
of an improvement on the game that was
played in the candidates tournament we
have uh H3 or maybe not an improvement
maybe just a nastier surprise or
something like that so H3 challenging
the bishop Bishop to H5 and now Bishop
to F5 now the bishop here controls a lot
of very important squares and this
bishop will be shifted over to F4 so
King to hate uh we have Queen to E2 and
now uh Queen to B6 putting pressure on
the B2 Pawn so Bishop to F4 uh
increasing the activity of the bishop
also the queen now defends the B2 Pawn
we have Rook 8 to E8 and now Rook 8 D1
putting pressure on the D5 Pawn so D4 by
another back and now Pawn to G4 with
Bishop to G6 and now Queen to C2 uh not
really putting pressure on anything but
uh I guess he uh if Bishop captures and
F5 he wanted to maybe have the option of
Queen captures it's hard to say because
G captures looks like such a such a
great uh option but okay Queen to C2 we
have rooked the d8 and now pawned the H4
preparing Pawn to H5 we have Queen to A6
by another back now putting pressure on
the A2 pawn and also preparing Pawn to
D3 as the D3 square is now guarded by
the queen and by The Rook uh yes it's
defended by Rook Queen and bashabot at
any point you can just pick up the the
bush pun F5 and then you're gonna
Advance the pawn to D3 so C capture C
captures we have Queen to B3 and now
Pawn to D3 another back continues
advancing his past pawn and now Pawn to
H5 here the the safe thing to do is uh
play Rook D3 put more pressure on the uh
D3 pawn and it's not a very exciting
move but that will be uh well
objectively the best but here Arjun
played Ponte H5 and here he sort of runs
in into trouble yes he forces Bishop
captures on F5 which allows G captures
on F5 and now Arjun will have some
uh E6 or F6 IDs at any point but now
Knight to D4 we have Knight captures on
D4 Rook captures on D4 and now Bishop to
G3 uh we have Pawn to the Q now
attacking the rook and E1 and now Rook
the E3 we have Queen to H6 now putting
pressure on the H5 pawn and queen
captures on B7 now if Queen captures an
H5 you can retreat with Queen to F3 uh
but first another big plays Bishop to G5
he puts pressure on The Rook here Rook
to C3 and now Queen captures an H5 so
Queen to F3 offering a queen trade uh
but just Queen to H3 uh here we have
Bishop to H2 again offering a queen
trade and Rook the G4 with check
and now the problem is you cannot play
King to each one uh if you play King to
H1 here uh then Queen to H5 is very very
strong if you continue with something
like Rook to D3 or pretty much any move
just Bishop to F4 and white resigns here
there's no way to stop Checkmate you're
gonna have to give up your queen here so
instead Bishop back to G3 not much more
you can do here and pawn to H6 we have
Queen to G2 again offering a queen trade
now comes Queen to H5 we have Pawn to F3
kicking away The Rook Rook the D4 and
now Queen to H2 again offering a queen
trade uh but here another Beck declines
the queen trade with pretty much the
only winning move but it's not that
difficult to spot because the queen
really doesn't have any squares okay if
if you want you can defend with G6 but
it doesn't look like something you want
to play uh so Bishop to H4 is definitely
the way to go now if you if you trade
just through captures and this is uh
just a really bad Queen G2 Queen
captures an F5 uh there's not much to
look for here with white so instead
after Bishop to H4 King the F1 was
attempted by Arjun but now Rook F to d8
with Bishop to F2 putting pressure on
The Rook uh but now the position is once
again completely winning for another
back uh so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the winning idea uh
while I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh wonderful idea and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Rook the E4 you sidestep the bishop and
now also you are threatening Rook to E1
in some lines and also uh you cannot
capture The Rook because Queen captures
and D1 comes with checks so here Pawn
the F6 was played uh but no derbeck just
captures G captures and F6 and he shows
that this is impossible if you capture
this uh then you free up the fifth rank
for the queen then just Queen to B5
check and you get checkmated look at
this queen to g king to G2 Rook to G8
with check King to H1 and now Rook the
E1 even this possible because now if
Bishop captures then uh Queen to F1 The
Rook no longer covers the F1 squares
they're gonna have to capture with the
Rook but this also doesn't help you
because after Bishop capture there's
always Queen to F1 with check and now
this will be Checkmate so after G
captures on F6 we have Queen the H3 but
now Rook the F4 uh again not not all
that much to do here uh Bishop captures
on A7 was played if maybe Arjun survives
then then the two connected pass pawns
will be able to do some damage averages
Queen captures on E5 with Bishop back to
E3 now attacking The Rook but now Queen
to B5 with Chuck King the G1 and now
Queen to E2 attacking The Rook on D1 so
Queen to F1 defending and now Rook to G8
with check King to H1 and here uh Arjun
tried to tried trading here Queen
captures Road captures but just Rook
captures on F3 by another Beck and he
was in this position on move 43 that uh
Arjun erigasi resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
there's no defense against both captures
uh and against Rook to H3 Checkmate
because the other recovers the G file
and what happens after you capture is of
course the black just gets a queen the
game and that's it very quickly you will
get checkmated Now The Rook will hang
and and so on one nice line for example
King H2 we need to check Rook death to
you you can even ignore this bishop G3
checking each one Queen H5 check King G1
Bishop H2 a nice double check from the
rook and the bishop and after King F1
Queen to D1 or Rook to G1 will be
Checkmate so uh too much stuff Happening
Here of course after Rook captures and
F3 Arjun resigns and another very nice
Victory uh for another backup to satrov
with the black pieces here his second
win in a row with the black pieces uh
first one being against uh Magnus costs
and then a draw like I said against
Prague in round six and now in round
seven another crushing win against Arjun
neregasi with the black pieces also very
very impressive Arjun also 27-22 uh not
not to be trifled with another seemingly
having a tournament of his life we'll
see if he'll be he will be able to
continue this until the very end but so
far the way he's playing it does appear
to be so uh so yeah that's the game I
hope you guys enjoyed it uh very very uh
nice attempt at uh at the Petra of
Defense uh following a line from the
candidates tournament but then finding
an improvement uh on what um Fabiano
played against so maybe like I said
maybe it was an improvement maybe maybe
it was just a trickier move to meet uh
but uh all in all uh got him a full
point here uh so yeah that's the game I
hope you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank Derek King Richard
Rob and classical is best for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Tata steel until it finishes plenty of
uh games uh that are really really
awesome here in round seven so we are uh
probably gonna check at least uh one
more if not if not more uh so yeah uh
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day